سيناقش الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
زيلينسكي مع نظيره الامريكي جو بايدن
الثلاثاء في واشنطن احتياجات اوكرانيا
الملحه والاهميه الحيويه لاستمرار الدعم
الامريكي لبلاده تاتي زياره زيلينسكي الى
واشنطن تلبيه لدعوه جو بايدن الذي يتطلع
الى التوصل الى اتفاق مع الكونغرس لتقديم
مساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا واسرائيل رغم
عرقله المعارضه في مرلس الشيوخ الاربعاء
مش مشروع قانون قدمه البيت الابيض لاقرار
مساعدات طارئه بقيمه 106 مليارات دولار
تستفيد منها بالدرجه الاولى اوكرانيا
واسرائيل وذلك على اساس ان مشروع القانون
لا يتضمن اصلاحات في مجال سياسه الهجره
هذا وكان البيت الابيض قد حذر البرلمانيين
من ان الاموال المخصصه لتقديم مزيد من
المساعدات لاوكرانيا ستنفد بحلول نهايه
العام في حال لم يوافق الكونجرس على تخصيص
اموال جديده لكيف هذا وتقدم الولايات
المتحده اكبر قدر من الدعم العسكري لكيف
حيث تعهد الكونجرس باكثر من 110 مليارات
دولار منذ الغزو الروسي في فبراير من عام